thank you mike giannis tell me what was
going through your mind
when that shot left kevin durant's hand
he looked good
but thank god he didn't went in pj was
right there
he contested the shot so that's all you
can do
and we'll be able to get the win yeah
just take me through that last defensive
stance
how are you guys able to hold them all
we're just playing together we just
trust one another
we just want to make it as tough as
possible for them we know
down the kd is going to have the ball
and
uh we're all you know ready for that you
guys were up big early
you came out really aggressively
especially you
what changed during the course of the
game wasn't able to
get the going down and uh i wasn't able
to get the
stops also but at the end of the day we
came back from pleasure we kept playing
together
we came across one another we kept
trusting our habits and now we're able
to stay in the game and uh
get the win you and chris kind of put
the team
on your back did you have any kind of
conversation before the game about
just what you guys needed to do to get
this one you know we've been doing this
for eight years
and we know what type of game this is
and we both came out ready uh
we were able to compete and we were able
to uh get our teammates to go
get in our spots and uh help the team
get a win
hopefully we can do it on game court
also yeah yeah you had to have this one
now it's a series how do you carry that
over
into game four we gotta keep playing
good basketball we gotta trust one
another
we gotta stay aggressive keep getting
stopped keep making the
stuff as possible for them and uh
hopefully we can you know
get ourselves in a position to get a win
and
if you do that you're going to be good
thanks giannis congratulations on the
win guys
all right lisa he said it's hard to get
the ball of the basket that was the case
in the fourth
but the bucks they shoot 38 from the
field
19 percent from three yet somehow
managed to get the victory and keep
themselves very much alive in this
series
their defense was terrific they held the
nets to a season-low 83 points
so now brooklyn's lead cut two games to
one coming up next the
utah clippers game two as the jazz took
game one of that